the rangers still have something to play
for
the silver boot is still up for grabs
and you may scoff
but i'll tell you these guys would love
to win it and they would love to keep
the astros out of the playoffs it'll be
lancelin on the mound for the rangers
we'll take a look at his impressive
season stats he's had 12 starts
excellent one loss record
excellent era george springer he is
one of the all-time greats already
lead off home runs 39. here's the 2-2
there's a swing and a miss
lin got him with a fastball at 93 when
the ball game is underway with george
springer striking out
now bring up alex bregman
bregman hits the ball on the line this
ball carrying in left field this ball is
down against the wall altuve heading
around third he'll be waved home he's
going to score bregman's got a chance at
three he'll go in with a triple and the
astros lead one nothing good swing by
alex he needed to feel that ball jump
off the bat it's been a while since he's
done that now tucker batting with a
two-strike count and two outs
fights this one off into shallow left
center field coming on to varys he drops
the ball leone tavares
dropped the ball in left center field
look playable and the astros will take
it for a two nothing lead
bottom of the first has christian javier
on the mound for the houston astros he
has pitched in 11 games nine games he
has started up to this point his whip
overall is under one at .99 doing a
great job holding opposing hitters to a
181 batting average
that ball hit high in the air playable
coming in from left field is kyle tucker
and he puts it away for the final out so
an initial double stranded in the astros
lead two numbers
george springer runners on first and
third and one out springer hits one to
deep center field this ball's hit well
and that ball is gone
astro's first run home run in the new
globe-like field is hit by who else
george springer a three-run shot and the
astros lead five to nothing
now javier will face rugnet o'dore 3-2
pitch swinging a mass and odor won't be
happy after that 3-1 pitch he thought he
had drawn a walk but that's the first
strikeout for christian javier went away
so now it's ronald guzman
swinging a miss upstairs and javier able
to get ronald guzman that keeps the
runner on third now with two outs
back-to-back strikeouts for the
right-hander that'll bring up correa
i'm gonna miss and that strikeout will
in the inning third strike out of the
night for lynn
go to the bottom of the third
rangers trail by five
so back to the
top of the order
a little more crisp there you go
80 mile an hour slider down and in gets
the swinging strike
third strikeout for javier here's dustin
garneau the one two swinging a miss
fastball near the top of his own will
get garneau
and for lance lynn that is his fourth
punch out of the evening
the problems that a lot of left-handers
hitters have
hitting against left-handed pitcher
duvet strikes out that's the
fifth of the night for lancelin
one and two the count to isaiah kinder
philippa who has flied out to center
field his first time up
and he goes down swinging here that
doesn't have a rise to it because it's
physically impossible but it appears to
rise as kind of swings underneath that
fastball
so here is alex bregman we need some
sort of bregman dugout celebration after
a home run you might get one deep to
left field zolac goes back and we have a
home run we are looking for alex bregman
his last home run was august the 11th
and he hits one out here a two run shot
now we need the dugout celebration as
the astros lead seven nothing that would
be special things as he faces rugnetto
door
[Applause]
got him high fastball rugnet odor has
struck out twice tonight that is five
strikeouts for javier
andrew romine had a tough and bad first
time up
swing and a miss so romine who had a
nine pitch battle his first time up goes
down on three pitches here as he gets
him with the slider for strikeout number
six
oh here's al tube batting with two on
and one out
altuve hits a fly ball in the left field
that'll send solac back he's still back
he's at the track he leaps up gone
jose altuve
a three run home run the astros up to
double figures it's 10 to nothing
all right calhoun
0 for two
against xavier and this one
in the air deep right field back to the
wall it is gone
a two-run homer for calhoun
it took a while
but really
gets his first home run of the year and
the rangers are on the board
still in the driver's seat if yorugi
look for a good one to hit and drive it
got men in second and third
when he drives this one out to right
field but right to redick
tagging at third base counter falafel
he'll score
so it's a sac fly for roogie
makes it 10-3 it's on a payoff from
garcia and here he comes and that one
lined over third headed down that left
field line that's a fair ball
drops in will bring home
romine and it's a double for calhoun
makes it 10-4
to 10 runs another run scored on an
error
reddick drives one towards right center
field that ball is going to be
gone home run into the rangers bullpen
home run number four for the astros
tonight josh redick a three hit night
and the astros now have a dozen runs
rangers down to their final out
ball hit to center field hit pretty well
but straw is there and that is the ball
game miles straw puts it away and the
astros are victorious 12-4